cheers to you family
i can't believe that i'm actually
getting to
do an interview with you so you're
re-teaming again with anne hathaway
which i'm freaking out because
i think that for most people the devil
wears prada is
one of our favorite films ever um
did you enjoy being like on set with her
again were you reminiscing
i loved it i i was very you know you
know you know what it's like every time
you make a movie it's like the first day
of school
kind of so you know you're always a bit
nervous and
i think particularly with andy it was
just so nice it was so easy
i mean when i was a kid thinking about
all the things that
i wanted to sort of do growing up or
what i loved about the world i was lucky
enough to be in
of films acting theater television
you know the whole thing was i loved
when i couldn't pin anyone down
you are so like that you do big giant
tent pole movies one minute
you're in the hunger games and like a
marvel movie
you'll do shakespeare and independent
films
and dramas are you conscious of wanting
to keep such a unique broad range
tapestry
what's your problem well i want i you
know what i think we all want to
i mean the whole point of it is
you want to be as many people as you can
be before you die
so and then what are the venues
that allow you to do that sometimes
they're in the
more commercial realm and sometimes
they're
in the independent realm
and sometimes it simply has to do
with oh i have to make money now
because i support my family yeah and
sometimes it's
like well i'm going to direct this movie
i've written this movie i'm going to
direct this movie it's going to take me
a year of my life or more and
i'll go broke doing it but it's okay so
it's really just about what you feel you
need
at any given time and making sure that
you're always challenging yourself
that's what
that's what's really important i think
when you see a script like julia and
julia or the devil wears prada
do you read it and go yep this is going
to be one of those movies that every
person is going to watch
500 times no no no i mean devil was
probably
yes well maybe both but i i don't know i
mean all i know is
i'll be honest about the devil wears
prada i was they were already
shooting and then they cast me i was the
last person
to be cast in in the film
but also with julian julia um
i was doing the lovely bones and just
prior to
doing that meryl had asked me
she said would you be interested would
you do this
role and you know of course i always
loved julia child i love
food i'm food obsessed um and when she
asked me i said yeah
what do you say no no i'm not gonna
with you and nora you know um so
yeah of course i did it and i was it was
just one of the happiest experiences
ever well it feels like that when you're
watching it and i
love the tapestry of your career so much
and people have such
respect when you say tucci people freaky
you know what i mean it's funny well
that's it i'm glad of it
yes
i'm so excited and by the way during the
quarantine
i know that you weren't sort of into
social media
you were you know on the other side of
it looking in
started an instagram account where you
make cocktails
and boom viral heaven yes a virus within
a virus
um i didn't expect it at all but it's
it's great it was
it's awfully fun to do well i think
people love touchy tucci tucci
and then you need cocktail cocktail
cocktail during a pandemic pandemic
pandemic
and if it's okay i have a delightful
young gentleman um that
this iconic seven-year-old who's better
known as the shirley temple king um
but will you will you make a drink with
us
i would i would never say no it reminds
me of my favorite do you remember our
art link letters kids say the darndest
thing yeah i do
actually yes okay so one of my favorite
episodes of that was he's asking a kid
like um what do your parents do
like around the house and the kids just
looking like wide-eyed and arts
art link letters like like what does
what does your
dad do like in the house does he cook
does he clean
does he does he work what does your dad
do around the house and the kid's just
looking looking like he goes
what does your dad do and he goes uh
makes cocktails
and i feel like i'm about to live out
that fantasy with you
and leo so we're gonna make cocktails
[Music]
you